and finally new rule if you hate all the
things that good liberals are supposed
to hate like environmental destruction
exploited labor greed gluttony and
disease you need to join me in calling
for an end to cruise ships and instead
of the 30-day pause that President Trump
announced today in a pledge to keep this
great and important industry going let's
take this opportunity to push the entire
disgusting business out to sea
and give it the Viking funeral its so
richly deserves if there is a silver
lining to pandemics it's that they force
Society to rethink traditions like
shaking hands chairing a dessert making
out with the dog and yes even passing a
joy well to that list we should add
cruise ships cruise ships are what
happens when someone asks what if my
hotel could sing let's not forget cruise
ships were terrible before Corona
calling a cruise ship a floating petri
dish was kind of funny the first 300
times some gross disease swept through
the cabins but it's not that funny
anymore because petri dishes are small
and controllable and stay locked in a
lab where they can't hurt anybody
cruise ships on the other hand are large
and quite difficult to control which is
why they keep crashing into things like
docks and rocks and each other
and that lack of control extends to the
interior of the ship as well if you're a
virus looking for a host a cruise ship
is like Spring Break Mardi Gras in Las
Vegas all rolled into one you're gonna
get laid but but unlike Vegas what
happens on a cruise ship does not stay
on a cruise ship when the corona virus
started infecting cruise ships all the
other viruses were like who's the new
guy now there's a lot of blame to go
around for letting this cat out of the
bag but until two weeks ago the largest
outbreak outside China over 700 people
was on a cruise ship then the Grand
Princess off San Francisco became the
second one I remember when guys in San
Francisco would be thrilled when the
fleet came in not anymore
these ships have simply gotten out of
hand look at this thing that's not a
cruise ship it's a Death Star
vacation looks like a floating housing
project Royal Caribbean has a ship now
that holds six thousand six hundred and
eighty passengers even smaller cruise
ships emit as much air pollution as a
million cars and pump a hundred and
fifty thousand gallons of sewage into
the ocean each week more if the potato
salad sat out and I hate to be a
vacation scold but the reason you can
afford a week of all-inclusive fun is
because in the middle of the ocean there
are very few laws or people to enforce
them kind of like Texas
scant labor laws so a kitchen worker for
the princess line works 13 hours a day
seven days a week for six straight
months it's not a Grand Hotel at sea
it's a slave ship with a food court you
may think the crew below deck is having
a rollicking good time because you
remember Titanic but the actual living
conditions are more like the room where
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself oh and
you know what's happened 322 times so
far this century on a cruise ship
someone fell overboard which is code for
got murdered really you think you're
going up top to play king of the world
next thing you know you're playing girl
from the opening of Jaws finally if
you've ever been on a cruise think about
your day onboard could you really do
anything you couldn't do on land they
have movie theaters and laser tag and
skinning rigs and Starbucks
congratulations you set out for the West
Indies and you made it to West Covina
I don't get the selling point our ship
will make you feel like you're not on a
ship at all there why go some of the new
ships actually have fake windows with a
screen that shows footage of the ocean
so you can imagine you're on a ship
while you are on a ship it's like having
sex while you fantasize about jerking
off
wouldn't you rather do this on the
actual ocean it's cheaper safer and [ __ ]
you don't have to sit through the
magician
you